We've been wondering for a while now and sort
of asking questions about whether we can trust
the corona virus numbers that we're getting.
And part of the reason why that's been in
question is that there have been reports that
individual states were choosing to suppress
data, maybe not so much about cases, but possibly
about deaths.
Florida was one place where we heard those
allegations made very specifically.
But now we have to talk about this at the
federal level because there are growing reports
that the Trump administration is coordinating
a suppression effort to prevent the real numbers
about Corona virus from getting out.
And we've actually gotten our hands on a memo
that was sent out, which specifically says
to hospitals, as of today, July 15, stop sending
the data to the CDC.
Instead, send it to the Department of Health
and Human Services, run by Trump Tool and
sycophant Alex Azar.
This is exactly what we predicted might happen
months ago if the numbers did not improve.
The New York Times reported yesterday that
hospitals have been ordered to bypass the
normal process.
The normal process is hospitals report to
the CDC and they were told, send us all of
your data, send it directly to the Department
of Health and Human Services.
This is the opposite of transparency.
This opens the door to just hiding the data.
And health experts obviously are alarmed because
they know exactly how this can go.
Now, we eventually got a copy of the order
from the Trump administration.
And what the document says to hospitals is,
don't send your information to the CDC, send
it to us.
And of course, that is a department, the Department
of Health and Human Services, that is run
by the guy Trump picked and who has been brownnosing
Trump since the start of this pandemic.
And in all of history, since the CDC was created,
pandemic data, health data like what we're
dealing with today goes to the CDC, the Kaiser
Family Foundation, which has no connection
whatsoever to the insurance company Kaiser
Permanente.
The Kaiser Family Foundation says, quote,
This is Jen Kates, the director of Global
Health and HIV Policy.
Jen Kates says, historically, the CDC has
been the place where public health data has
been sent.
And this raises questions.
I love the understated nature.
This raises questions about not just access
for researchers, but access for reporters,
access for the public to try to better understand
what is happening with the outbreak.
How will the data be protected?
Will there be transparency?
Will there be access?
And what is the role of the CDC in understanding
the data?
Now, you need only zoom out like the tiniest
bit to understand what is most likely going
on here.
Donald Trump admitted that he wanted to slow
down testing in order to cover up the reality
of the pandemic.
Rember, he said, one of the reasons we have
so many cases is we have so many tests.
Now, this ignores a whole bunch of realities.
In fact, if you don't test, it doesn't affect
the real number of cases, except it probably
increases the real number of cases because
without testing, people don't know they have
the virus and they go out and they spread
it.
So not testing actually spreads the disease.
Additionally, as testing has gone up in many
of the states that are worst affected, the
positivity rate has gone up.
If you go from 5000 to 10000 tests a day and
you go from having two percent of the people
test positive to four percent, that is a signal
of a growing epidemic.
This is all way beyond Donald Trump.
He doesn't seem to understand any of this
stuff.
So the point is, once you understand, Trump
admitted to wanting to slow down testing,
to slow down case numbers, and you see that
the Trump administration is saying the hospitals
don't send your data to the CDC.
Send your data to Alex Azar at HHS.
The obvious next step is to start covering
up this data, cover up death data, cover up
hospitalization data.
The White House is trying to muzzle the normal
reporting process, and the only reason that
that exists is to suppress information.
If he can't stop the testing, he'll stop the
information.
Now, I'm hoping I don't I don't know.
I've talked to a few people today and they
have different opinions that could this work
because there are other ways to get the data
out.
Media will talk to hospitals and hospitals
will say, well, we'll say we're full.
We have no room in the ICU, for example.
And at a certain point, if the data that the
Trump administration is allowing to be published
says one thing that goes completely against
what the ICU information is, at a certain
point, you would hope that it would explode.
That the real data has been covered up.
I don't know.
I mean, I'm hopeful that this can't really
be covered up to this degree, but the administration
has decided the numbers must go down, that
the numbers have to go down for the benefit
of Donald Trump's reelection.
Here's one way to do it.
Now, what we can hope for is that we still
find the data and that Trump is punished electorally
for trying to suppress the data rather than
dealing with the pandemic itself.
It's too early to know which way it will go
because the directive starts today.
It's effective as of July 15th.
So we'll have to see what happens.
But what we need to understand is that from
this point forward, from as if this wasn't
already the case in many of the states in
the United States already from this point
forward, we have to realize that the numbers
that make it out may not be the real numbers,
because the idea is hide the data to justify
a faster economic opening to help Donald Trump
get himself reelected.
His reelection is the most important factor.
It's far more important than American lives.
And it's really the only thing you need to
know to understand how to analyze the actions
of this administration.
It seems to run counter to health.
It seems to run counter to common sense.
It seems short sighted in terms of the economy
because the relapse effect will hurt the economy.
You just have to understand, Trump thinks
it might help him get reelected in November.
That's all that's going on.
The pandemic response has been blown so badly
that there's really no way to fix it before
the election.
I was looking at some data today, and this
is important for you to understand.
When New York hit its peak right around April
twelve, April 15, something like that, that's
when New York had its peak of cases.
It took two full months with strict lockdowns
for New York cases to come down.
Remember that deaths lag cases by about 15
to 20 days.
So by.
April, May, June, by mid-June, you finally
had this improving in New York.
And only in the last 10 days in July have
New York's death numbers really finished coming
down to, you know, a number that hopefully
they won't spike again from.
So you take that model two months for cases
and then another fifteen or so days, four
deaths.
If Arizona and Florida and Texas fully locked
down today, if they don't even want you.
But if they did that, you're looking at September
15th to get cases under control and October
1st to get what is the coming spike of deaths
back under control.
They're not willing to do it.
I mean, yeah.
Greg Abbott now is saying more.
You've got to wear a mask.
But these are not places that seem to have
an appetite politically or economically or
in any other way for a full lockdown.
So Trump recognizes the numbers aren't going
to be under control.
When you get to 10, 15000 cases a day, that
doesn't just go away in two weeks.
They are going to be dealing with widespread
outbreaks until close to election time if
we have the surging second wave.
By then, it could be even worse.
We're now hearing from the CDC that this fall
may be one of the most difficult times in
American history.
From the standpoint of public health.
So what can Trump do?
Just lie.
Cover up the data.
That's all that they can do to hide the data.
Use the data.
We'll use the data you're willing to publish,
which is not accurate to say we should reopen
re-open in order to make things seem normal
so that people will vote for you in the fall.
Hopefully the real data makes it out.
But this is now taking on the sort of color
of a full cover up because the actual remember,
it would have been rather than covering up
data, changing reporting procedure, all of
the stuff.
It would have been much easier to just deal
with the virus from the get go.
That's not what this administration chose
to do.